now he created the office gave us extras
and now he is managing to make grief a
little lighter back for a third series
ricky gervais's afterlife has resonated
widely during the pandemic skies claire
gregory caught up with the comedian
along with some of the cast to discuss
how the show came together
i wish i teased her about there not
being an afterlife now i think she
wanted to believe in like heaven and
angels and stuff in the height of the
pandemic in spring 2020 grief was all
too close to home and ricky gervais's
story of a widower had audiences in
tears of sadness and laughter and went
on to become the most watched british
comedy program in the world the realer
someone is the better the performance
the the more you the more you laugh at
the jokes and the more you cry at the
sad bits
trying to come over later i haven't even
finished and like with some of his
previous creations it's hard to know
where the character ends and your vase
begins
i think people have got this idea that
ricky's uh
quite arrogant yeah and a bit like david
brent
yeah and he is he's exactly like there
is a touch there is a touch
the main problem with ricky is the
director is that he just finds
everything funny so
like genuinely it can be a but i mean
there'd be scenes we've done in series
two when i was doing those things with
paul k he had to leave the room and be
listening to it on cans and we could
still hear him laughing outside the door
yeah i mean it was ridiculous i ruined
most takes yeah so that i mean that's
his that's your sort of uh your greatest
flaw i think as a director is that you
sabotage your own work
in the aftermath of the muted and scaled
back golden globes last week gervais's
scathing speeches as hosts in 2020 now
hold a special place in awards history
he's also the only person who ben
affleck hasn't been unfaithful to
please welcome matt damon
the first time i did it um 10 years ago
people were going why is he saying awful
things these lovely these most important
people in the world and the world
changed and by the fifth time they were
going yeah go on give it to him we're
sick of them we're sick of celebrities
he's a baby
yeah but he's not the one making all the
noise is he you are yeah to keep him
amused because if he was crying that
would only people wouldn't do it no it
wouldn't because he's a baby for those
missing gervais's caustic wit this final
series will be welcome and will leave
many viewers wondering what's next for
him after after life claire gregory sky
news